- Let me promise everyone here.
You wanna win in 2021,
be nicer.
(plane whirring)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(plane whirring)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Welcome Gary Vaynerchuk
to Datto Keynote 2021.
- I am so happy to be here.
Thank you so much.
I clearly, you spoke to
my mom before that intro.
You're very, very sweet.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody for having me.
I'm extremely excited
to get into this talk
and really to be frank, get into the Q&A
because I love the practicality of that.
So we'll be getting to that in the backend
for some of you that don't know me.
I am a kind of born entrepreneur back
to the lemonade stand
franchise and sports cards
which are backed by the way now.
I'm in my teenage years and you know,
my family lived the American dream.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
We came to this country with so little.
We lived in Studio
Apartment with, you know,
my grandma my great grandma,
my great grandfather,
like real, real immigrant stuff.
And, we kind of made our way, you know
my parents quickly had a second child,
my sister, Liz and it was a grind there
in the late 70s, early 80s
but my dad had a great
uncle who had a liquor store
and he gave him a job
and he built himself up
and eventually became the manager
and eventually bought his own store
in Springfield, New Jersey.
By the time it was 14,
I did have those, you know,
eight, nine years of sales,
marketing, and branding experience.
And I'm not kidding.
You know, it's funny knowing
the audience for this talk.
I think of myself as a salesman.
I think of myself as a CEO.
I think of myself as a
marketing and brand person.
And I think all of them matter.
And I think they all have
interesting, different nuances,
different things that you start with,
different KPIs, different energies.
But I think all of them have something
to take out of this world,
which I'll get into in a minute.
And I think a lot of people on this call
don't realize why producing
two different videos
or pictures or written
words a day on LinkedIn
can really change their
career financially,
and to be very frank, happiness.
And we'll get into that in a minute.
So, you know, by the time I was 14,
I felt like I was a pro you know,
singing Christmas carols
for a dollar shoveling snow.
I was a very unique
kid that when it snowed
or when the summer started,
my initial reaction was, it snowed,
Oh, let's get shovels, ring doorbells
make two bucks, five
bucks later, 10 bucks.
When first day of summer,
it's like let's get our lemonade game on.
Let's go.
I mean, I remember my friend Marissa bird
carrying a huge hose
twice a week in the summer
because we were gonna be
washing cars for five bucks.
It was just always there.
And my lemonade business, you know
I learned how to manage kids.
I mean this is just real now,
it's seven, eight, nine years old.
I learned how to motivate my friends,
AKA manipulate and trick them
into standing behind a table
for six hours in the
summer to sell lemonade.
But I learned what the power of marketing
and branding intention.
I literally, this is
crazy to me in hindsight.
I had the epiphany actually on stage
somewhere in my late thirties,
that this is what I did
cause I would always
tell the lemonade story.
And I was like, why?
You know, what did I do when
they were behind the tables?
And I was like, wait a minute.
I was making signs and going
around the neighborhood.
This was the 80s where
six-year-olds could run free.
I would walk around the
neighborhood and put up signs.
I would even sit and watch cars drive by
and try to figure out
which tree or which post
would be most likely seen by the driver,
so that they would buy my lemonade.
And at seven years old, eight
years old in 1982 in 83,
I clearly started my obsession
and my curiosity around
customers' attention.
That played out huge in
my baseball card business
because the way I set
up my tables was very...
Get people's attention
when they were walking
through the convention or
the firehouse or the mall.
And then it really was an
impact on my dad's business
and the way that I set up the
store when I first got there
and moved things around
and maximized our business
by impacting people, buying more things
because it was merchandised better.
I watched customers.
I watched customers from 14 to 22.
I worked in that liquor store
behind the register bagging
ice, stocking shelves.
And I just watched people.
How they walked.
What they picked.
Listening to them.
Talking to them, listening,
listening, listening
listening, listening,
listening, and realizing that
if I could bring them what they wanted
more so than what I wanted out of it.
If I had compassion,
empathy, sympathy to them
not to my greed or
ambition, or self-interest
that I would have leverage, right?
Think about right now,
the person in your company
or in your life that
you most value, right?
Think about that person.
That person is providing you value.
That's why...
And think about how much
leverage that person has, right?
Think about the fact that that person
because they bring you so much value
has leverage in your relationship.
Like you don't want them to
stop doing what they're doing.
You don't want them to leave, quit.
You don't want them to break up with you.
And so, I really think the
kindness is the ultimate leverage
that bringing value is
the ultimate leverage.
And I think about that constantly.
And I think about that in
sales, leadership, marketing.
I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses
for my dad in 1996, winelibrary.com.
As a matter of fact, if you are into wine,
please go to Wine, Text
Text.com right now,
I just stood up a new thing
for my dad 18 months ago,
that's changed his life.
It's a daily deal via text on wine.
It's completely changed his business.
And the reason I'm
bringing it up is twofold.
One, I love my dad and I don't think...
And I love my dad, actually three reasons.
One, I love my dad the most
that I'd like you to buy wine from him.
Two, it's the dem best wine
service on the internet.
Today we're selling a
$65 Cabernet for $26.
So that's good.
That's good for you.
But three and most importantly
I want all of you to learn text marketing.
I think SMS is emerging.
And one thing I wanna
leave this talk with is
Clubhouse, and SMS and Tick
Talk and LinkedIn changes.
I'm a practitioner.
I'm not an author or a speaker,
I happen to be one but
the reason I'm a good one
is because I'm a practitioner.
I spent 12, 14 hours a day,
operating something called
VaynerX and VaynerMedia,
which is a Marketing
and Communications Infrastruction Company.
And I have the GaryVee thing, right?
I'm producing content on a daily basis.
These are really remarkable variables,
and the fact that I believe a
lot of authors are intellects.
I believe a lot of speakers are educators.
And I think that's amazing.
And I love that, but I
genuinely enjoy the fact
that I'm living your life.
All of you, whether it's sales
whether it's management,
whether it's marketing,
well, whether it's leadership
and I do 2021 is the greatest
opportunity era of all time.
I literally believe that
2021 for our businesses
selling SAS, selling
hardware, selling hoodies.
This is the best year ever to do business
because the advancements of technology,
the lack of gatekeepers controlling
what you can and can't do,
the end buyer meant the ecosystem.
I think people focus
so much on the negative
whether it's political
unrest, whether it's, you know
overwhelming with technology
whether it's self-esteem issues
and mental health issues.
And I think all of those things are true.
I also believe that in life you
see what you're looking for.
In life, I believe you see
what you're looking for.
And for me,
I think the word optimism
is grossly misunderstood.
I believe that cynical
people, unhappy people
look at the word optimism
and they think it's delusion.
But the reason there's a word
in dictionary called delusion,
and the reason there's a word
in the dictionary called optimism,
is because they're wildly different.
I come from immigrant beginnings.
I'm always scared to go
back to that place, right?
Subconsciously, I feel it,
but it's clearly there.
It makes me uncomfortably practical.
However, I fear no one step or two steps
or three steps backward.
I don't overvalue money.
It allows me to innovate.
It allows me to figure out things earlier.
I built one of the largest e-commerce
and retail wine businesses in America
as a 22, 23 24 year old,
in a world where the
internet was still small.
In a world where I had
no venture capital money.
In a world where I out executed everyone.
And it was completely religious
about what can I do for you?
Period, end of story,
which led to delivery
from the internet is more convenient
than driving 45 minutes to my dad's store.
It meant when somebody had a bad delivery,
I would throw a case of
Beringer White Zinfandel
in my car and drive 40
minutes and deliver it,
even if that excrewed up.
It meant that when an employee looked sad,
I asked them, are you okay?
And when they said their mom was sick,
I said, go home, I got this.
Like, let me promise everyone here.
You wanna win in 2021?
Be nicer.
Have more compassion.
You wanna lead in 2021?
Lead with this, not with
what your head thinks
your wallet is gonna benefit from.
And I know that I'm sounding
fluffy and (indistinct),
but let there be no confusion.
I'm gonna assess it when
it comes to business.
You may be hearing fluffy things,
but let me get real close to
the camera here my friends.
I'm trying to win the whole thing.
I'm trying to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time.
I believe that kindness,
compassion, empathy, sympathy
first for your employees,
then for your customers,
and then you can think about yourself
is not mother Teresa stuff,
it's not Gandhi, Nelson Mandela stuff.
I believe that it is surely
and obviously the foundation
of successful business in
today's transparent universe.
Your meanness that you
think is motivating,
it can't be hidden the way it used to be.
And so, I want people to
lead with optimism, kindness
and all these kinds of soft skills,
because I think there are
the emerging superpowers of business.
And I think a lot of you
should really be paying attention to it.
I also think that
all of these things
that we're talking about
can be scaled, right?
So my career is going along nicely.
And then, and I'm winning on
email marketing 90% open rates,
and I'm winning on Google AdWords
the day comes out and
buying every wine term
that's working for my dad.
And then comes along YouTube.
And I see this platform
and I say to myself,
there's something here.
And, you can run Ads
on the top at the time.
So my decide to do a show.
I'd never thought out of
myself, this gift of...
I thought to myself that gift the gab,
but more like a good salesman
or class clown that teacher kind of liked.
And so I didn't realize
what I was gonna be able
to do in that format,
but I started a very big show
that garnered a lot of attention
and it really really worked.
And it really got going
and it really taught me,
Oh my God, I don't have
to spend marketing money.
This attention is
trickling down organically
to my dad's business.
There's something here.
And then Twitter came out
and I started using it
to promote Wine Library TV.
And I'm like,
Oh my God, this Friendster, Myspace thing
is about to become much bigger.
This so...
It wasn't called Social Media yet,
it was called Web 2.0.
Twitter was known as a Web 2.0 App
and started using it.
And Google buys YouTube for $1.7 billion.
And I say to myself,
Oh my God, I was right about this,
I was right about Google AdWords,
I was right about Email.
I'm bet.
I'm not a wine retailer.
I understand what people are gonna do.
I need to become an investor.
And what I think people are going to do.
In 2007, I invested in
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr,
And that obviously changed my life.
My brother was graduating from college.
I was starting to make
videos about business
that were catching people's attention.
And in 2009, I decided
to start being a media
to do marketing for the
biggest brands in the world.
So I could learn big business
because I understood Silicon Valley.
I understood small
business entrepreneurship
but I didn't understand
executive fortune 500 land.
And I didn't understand why
they were doing so many
silly things in a world
where I thought Netflix, Facebook, Amazon
were going to be the next big thing.
And they turned out to be way bigger
than I even kind of predicted
even though I was
predicting the tippy top.
And so that's been my career.
I've written five New York
times bestselling books
around marketing and consumer
behavior and psychology.
But what does all this
hyperbole around me mean?
It means that, I believe that every person
who's watching this
right now is me in 2009.
Here's what I mean by that.
I had a level of success.
I was good.
I was enjoying myself.
I was building a big
company for my parents.
I was excited to think about
what I was gonna do for myself next.
But the scale of the internet
by using the tools
completely changed my life.
And I believe that what the
internet does is exposes things.
So I don't think the internet changed me.
I don't think it made me nicer
and stronger at my craft.
I think it made more people aware
that I was nice and strong in my craft.
And so, I think for everybody
who's watching right now
I don't think they realize
that if they started
producing content on LinkedIn
about what they know.
Not what you think people
want, not to get followers,
but to put out content of what you know
storytell my grand Pappy
taught me when I was 10.
This, I now did this for
my sales person today.
That's the video.
You don't have to be an expert.
I'm not an expert.
I'm a person that has
hypotheses and opinions.
And because a lot of them
became true after 15 years
and I've put the actual
business wins on the board.
Now people look at me in a
different way, but I don't even,
you know, even the
flattering, introduction
and our talk beforehand,
you know, she makes me feel so good,
but I don't think that makes me special.
I think it's just a nice
feeling to be admired, you know?
And, I think when you lay
your humility and curiosity
around being good at a
tool, great things happen.
Let me give you an example.
When books came out,
yeah, I'm being serious now,
clearly and I have no knowledge of this
but this is very easy to understand.
Clearly, there were individuals
who became more aggressive
at reading them and amassed knowledge.
And my intuition is, the ones
that were able to be practical
and operating were able to do something
with that knowledge and succeed.
When tractors and innovation hit farming,
the people that didn't
demonize it and many did
many said, that's not real farming
because they were
fearful that it was gonna
take away jobs from their
people, which was a nice thing.
But they were trying to fight technology,
which is always the wrong answer.
Let there be no confusion.
If you hear or feel
anything from this keynote
and Q&A today, please let it be this.
If you are fighting against
technology, you will lose.
It is the history of mankind.
Tractor comes along,
people fought against it.
The humans that adopted it,
learned it and use the best
built the biggest farms.
CNN and ESPN and MTV did this
to regular television and society.
Facebook and AOL and
you know, Google did it
to their growth in social.
The personalities that
tried to build brand
in the mid two thousands personal brands,
they've gone on to do things
like this is just too obvious
that the breakthrough
in our humanity today
whether you wanna want to
marry or whether you wanna
build a big business, whether
you wanna cure cancer,
whether you wanna raise
some money for the PTA,
it is a round content and it's
around you being self-aware
and you worrying it's, there's two words.
Self-awareness and self-esteem.
If you're self-aware,
you don't try to do things you can't do.
You focus on things you do like
you don't try to be something you're not.
If you have self-esteem, you're
not scared to put it out,
the content, the video,
the picture, the audio,
because you're not
worried if Sally pants 49
thinks you're ugly.
You're not worried that Rick Thompson
from a competitive company
says you're stupid.
You're just not worried.
You're not worried that you
have bags under your eyes
or you're overweight, or
you're losing your hair.
You're just not worried.
You're, focused on your self esteem.
You're focused on yourself.
You're focused on your self-awareness.
What's put you in a position to succeed.
And so all of you
One of the worst, not worst.
One of the challenging times
of my career was around 2012.
When people all wanted to be like me.
And I'm a very, very over the
top high energy personality
who's very, very comfortable on video.
And that is just not gonna
be the case for everybody.
And I tell everybody.
And it took me a while to
get to this good answer
which I think has helped
people listen to my friends.
If you're watching this
right now and be like,
Okay, I see what Gary setting up.
He's gonna ask me to start
producing a lot more content.
That's the answer by the way.
Well, I don't want to do video.
Well, my good news, Sarah,
you don't have to do video you my...
For example, I'm a terrible writer.
If I was a great writer,
I may be writing a lot more.
Cause writing on LinkedIn crushes.
As a matter of fact, my team loves when
I write all the copy on
my Instagram posts, right?
All of them, everyone,
every post in my life.
And they get pumped when I get motivated
and like write a real good one,
cause we know the post does better.
Copy is the most underrated
thing in social media today.
It drives so much of the success
of the picture in the video.
So, by the way, you might be an audio.
You might be a talker, but
you're insecure about your visual
of how you look or the
camera makes you freeze.
But you're great with talking so good.
There's now clubhouse, an incredible app
you can go and be a thought leader.
There's just recording audio
and posting that on your LinkedIn.
LinkedIn for this group,
knowing who's in the room
is equivalent to what
Facebook was in 2012.
That will lead to incredible
financial and emotional success
to those in here that heed the
call that I'm yelling today.
Period, end of story.
I could not be more passionate
about everybody here getting very serious.
And then what you put out, is up to you.
You know, my recommendation
is that it brings value to people,
whether it's entertaining
whether it's informational,
but I also believe that stories,
stories are easier for people.
This is something that I'm gonna
start talking a lot
about, a lot more about.
I think, stories, just
stories like life lessons.
Grandma told me.
And then if you're good at,
and I've already taught,
brought this up, I'm bring it up again
because I'm trying to help everybody here.
Give you some training wheels.
If you say hi, I'm
Karen, I'm a sales leader
at this company.
I, this is for my team
but honestly this has been a broader world
cause I all you sales
leaders, I know how it is.
You know, when I was nine,
my grandmother took me
to a girl Scouts event
and Sarah Johnson did this
and my grandma, I did this and
grandma told me to do that.
Then I did this and me and Sarah Johnson
were best friends in high school.
And that's ironic,
because I had a big tiff
between Carl and Carla
recently on my team.
And I did this, like my grandma did that
and now they just closed the
biggest account together.
That story that should
come very naturally.
And by the way, you don't need to call out
Carla and Carla, right?
Cause that's (indistinct).
You're in the world right now.
You can be two people on my team.
Just think about how easy
that is for what everyone's
struggling with, which
is, well, what do I post?
What do I post is grounded
in lack of self-esteem
and lack of strategy
Period.
And so, I'm here today
to build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way.
I'm just trying to encourage
you to realize how real this is
because the content creators
that build awareness
and audiences will have
the leverage in business
whether it's a small narrow world.
And by the way, this is
a small narrow sector.
Most of the business people on this call
and this thing, that's great actually.
The reality is, that's great
because then you run a couple
of dollars in ads on LinkedIn
against targets of companies
that are in your sector,
and you're getting exactly who you want.
I actually like when groups are narrow
because you can get so much more specific.
So anyway, I'm just
very excited to be here.
I want to encourage everyone
to realize the opportunity.
The internet is not a gatekeeper.
You know, there's so many platforms
as people talk about big tech
and you could build outside
of big tech all day long,
there's so much going on
and there's so much opportunity,
so much opportunity.
And I hope you see it.
And I hope you understand
the emotional intelligence
needed to attack it.
And I hope that you start to
educate yourself practically.
And I think the reason
I like to set up Q&A
for a big portion of this
is, this is the macro thesis.
Be practical and optimistic,
produce countenance,
scale around stories,
information, entertainment,
and knowledge.
Bring as much value to your community,
rinse and repeat in
perpetuity for 15 years.
That's the thesis.
Now the question becomes
what are the specifics underneath it?
And I think this is a good
segue to get into the Q&A.
So, thank you for having me.
And I think we're gonna
get into the meat right now
of this keynote and I'm excited.
And by the way, any of you
that are not here right now,
my Twitter is Gary V E E since
I'm not tapped into a chat
or anything like this, sometimes
I like to just get a vibe,
or questions on that format
while I'm doing live streams.
So, Gary V E E if you just tweet at me
and just say any feedback
or follow up questions,
I can weave it into my
answers a little bit here
while I get these incredible questions.
So, thank you so much everybody,
I'm ready to keep going.
- Thank you, Gary.
That was absolutely fantastic.
We really appreciate your
time and your generosity
and I cannot wait to dive
into these questions.
So, we'll take a step back for a minute
and first ask you, how are
you doing as we head into 2021
and how did 2020 change
kind of your every day
and your company?
- Doing great.
Thank you for asking.
You know, I stopped traveling as much.
I got more sleep.
I put on 15 pounds of muscle
since super pumped about that.
You know, family time
got a tremendous amount
of time with my parents
which I think is something
I'll look back on
as a great blessing of this time.
You know, it actually allowed
me to focus very heavily
on VaynerMedia, VaynerX,
which I think led us
to a much stronger foundation
of success going forward.
So, I'm grateful for that.
I got to work on something
called the all-in challenge
where Michael Rubin,
the founder of Fanatics
stood up a nonprofit
concept that I helped him on
and strategized on and then
executed on, which ended being
a $60 million raise for
the hungry during COVID.
So, I got this between that
and pencils of promise.
And I got to really kind of scratch
the give back part of my life.
It allowed me to stand up something called
T with Gary V, a show
that I did during COVID
and I'm actually gonna bring back.
It let me...
But I miss traveling and I
miss interacting with people
in a face-to-face environment,
but it did allow me
to long-term be more
efficient in my business.
Know when to use video versus in-person
both for internal and external.
I think that's gonna
make me much stronger,
more happy and successful
in 2022, 2023, 2024.
- Yeah, absolutely.
What about from a sales perspective?
Did 2020 impact or change how
your sales organization works,
or do you see lasting impact
for businesses on a whole,
based on what happened last year?
- I just think last
year exposed everything,
You know, outside of restaurants and,
you know, there are clearly
some haves and havenots
winners from a COVID environment.
But I think for me, it was just about,
it was just about focus and reality,
practicality and just a
lot of great learnings.
- Yeah. I think one of
the things that get,
came up in a lot of your
videos throughout COVID,
and for those of you who are
watching throughout 2020,
was the optimism that you brought up
at the beginning of this conversation.
And I think it's so important
because when you ask about,
well, how was your 2020?
You pulled out all of the good things
just now when you answered
and not any negatives.
And I think that's really interesting
but it's also a lesson
that we can all take away.
So, don't want to take away
from the challenges of 2020 at all?
- No__
- Of course people have them.
- I think (indistinct)
- Yeah, and I'm sorry to throw up.
- No you can.
- It's a really interesting
observation, right?
Because to your point, to
me, my great grandmother
and grandmother came from the Old Country
and really almost every
time they drank tea
or when the men were drinking vodka,
you'd always kind of do this thing
where you spoke to good health.
Know, everything was to good health
to good health, to good health.
And I think it brainwashed me
in the greatest way of all time.
I, for me 2020
is a year that has
incredible underlining pain
for a lot of people who
feel that they were robbed
of years with people they love.
I am one of the lucky people
that did not have that happen.
And so thus, after that, you know
Vayner SPeakers and Vayner
Productions took massive hits,
lost millions of dollars.
It doesn't register,
because that's business,
that's almost like not real life.
Like money's not real life.
Real life is very basic.
Do the 12, 15, 20 people I
love, did they live in 2020?
And yes, amazing best year ever.
And, you know, I also am a good operator,
but I will say this.
If I owned 15 restaurants,
it would been...
and we were mandated to
close, now from my perspective
because I always believe in innovation,
I believe my DoorDash and UberEats
and direct to consumer would
have been stood up already.
And I probably would have grown.
And I think it forced a lot of restaurants
to finally do the right things.
And so, it's just a
really interesting time.
If you're a capable operator
and you have life in a simplistic mindset,
you're going to be happy way more often.
- Yeah. I think that's a great point.
And something we can all
take away from this is
to choose the good, right when we're faced
with those difficult challenges.
It's not the challenge that defines us,
but how we get through
it and how we innovate
and how we adapt, at the end of the day.
And so, I'd like to jump
into some tactical questions.
And we, what's nice about this audiences.
We're kind of a mix, right?
We have sales, support,
marketing, implementation success.
We're all here together.
So some of the questions
will mean more to teams
than the others, but I think
we can all learn from these.
So, in one way or another,
we're all content creators, right?
We have our content team for sure,
but training and implementation
creates training videos
for our partners.
Sales is constantly
the face of the company
and creating content in
one way or the other.
So, what's the greatest
lesson in terms of content
that you've learned over the years
that you might wanna share with the team?
- When you're a sales driven organization,
the most important thing
to do with content,
is make it brand.
Content on the internet is everyone hears
opportunity to offset the
aggressiveness of what is sales.
It's an opportunity to
provide value to the audience.
It's a way to provide affinity
towards you and your company
by showing humanity.
AK, silly things like just think
of the office, the TV show.
Like if you have somebody funny
in your company named Ricky,
like get Ricky on video, because
it shows a different side
to what everyone's accustomed to
which is the cold LinkedIn,
the cold email, the cold call
the very quick to, hey, let's
do business at a conference.
So, the biggest thing I've learned
for sales driven organizations,
which is amazing.
I love sales driven
organizations, you know?
Is thinking about content
as your appetizer to the
sales being the meal.
If you have a great appetizer
you're setting up a great meal.
And so, I think the biggest mistake,
I see it over and over and over and over
and over and over in these dynamics
is that people use
content as a sales engine,
instead of a brand engine.
Nike, doesn't cold call
you, or knock on your door
and ask you to buy their sneakers.
And even when you think
about Salesforce and SAP
even though they have great
sales, DNA, and infrastructure
there's so much brand
going on for a reason.
You need to have that offset, right?
You need to have that
honey to the vinegar.
good cop to the bad cop.
Content on LinkedIn is the good cop.
And I think that is a
very difficult maneuver
for the DNA of most of the people
that are watching this right now.
Period.
And that's okay.
That doesn't mean you're bad.
It doesn't mean you're stupid.
It means that there's a
humongous, uncomfortable,
monstrous opportunity that
if you heed this strategy
of what I'm talking about
and start implementing it,
like why not do an hour of Q&A on LinkedIn
and just answer questions.
Everyone's so fear-based,
and so like lack of,
you know people are not abundant, right?
Like I could weigh all my best advice.
I'm not scared of somebody
starting another agency
or another agency taking it.
Like, it doesn't matter,
the world's abundant.
I'm gonna get mine.
- Why, do you think it is that people
in sales driven organizations
might have that fear?
And what advice can you
give to kind of overcome it?
Because like you said, there's
this monstrous opportunity,
but sometimes there's a
lot of hesitation there.
- Almost everybody thinks
that resources are limited
and they have an almost,
everybody has a boss.
I don't have a boss.
So, it's easy for me to talk this way.
You know, I have empathy and compassion
for somebody who's listening
right now and does a seminar
and gives away a lot of great advice
and their boss coming to them and saying,
what the hell are you doing?
That's like, how we get clients
and then they get fired
or lose their bonus
or are pegged down in the organization.
Unfortunately, fear is
remarkably effective
and a real human trait.
I just don't believe in it.
And so what I, you know
I just believed that there's
so much more financial
and by far there's more financial,
but by far there's so much
more happiness on the back
of going with optimism and
abundance says your mindset.
And so, I think it's culture.
I think it's the industry culture
for many, many, many, many years.
And, I think that business
has historically had a cold
you know, kill or be
killed kind of mentality.
And, you know, I think
of sports a little bit.
I think business more like sports.
I, as a fan gets so
angry after a jets game
when my jets lose and they
go and hug all their friends
on the other team cause I'm pissed.
But the reality is I
actually fully understand it.
I want to kill, crush,
destroy, defeat, outmaneuver,
everybody I compete with at every second.
It is my DNA.
However, not at the
detriment of their lives.
Like, I wanna do 10 trillion
and I want you to do 9 trillion.
And that's how I think.
And I wish more people
realized how real that is
and how true that can be.
Then that's what I think about.
- Great, thank you so much.
I think something else you mentioned
that I wanna pull on a little bit is,
you mentioned Nike
and how they go about doing what they do.
And I think a really
interesting thing for us is,
we're a business to business organization.
And I think a lot of companies
in that B2B world say,
okay, we're B2B.
So we're gonna do marketing and sales
the way B2B should do it,
but there's so many lessons we
can learn from the B2C world.
And I think, you know, there's hesitation
to step outside of that box
and do something a B2C company might do.
So, what lessons can we learn from B2C
to help us differentiate
ourselves in the market?
- First of all, B2C is
just far more creative
because they don't use
the laziness of well
we're in B2B, we can't
do that as an excuse.
But just start with that.
You know, I think that B2B marketing to me
is actually more exciting
than B2C marketing
because I think LinkedIn is
in this 2012 to 14 Facebook place.
And I think the impact of
winning something in B2B
is so much greater than B2C.
So I put out a good, you know, right hook
in this Keynote to WineText.com, right?
And four people sign up
and that's awesome, right?
However, if VaynerMedia got a client
out of this call for being
or talent or a Sasha group,
that's so much more significant.
That's like 4,005,000 people
signing up for WineText.
I think the stakes are
so high in B2B marketing,
and I think B2B marketing,
the way it's supposed to be
or hasn't been done is garbage,
like spending money at a conference
where you see the same
people like you like cool.
But like, people are
spending real money on booths
and real money on full-page
Ads in print and B2B magazines.
Like, let's listen, let's speak
to the elephant in the room.
The B2B industry, for the most part,
especially if they do under
250 million in top line revenue a year,
they're not in the marketing business,
they're in the sales business.
It's all sales.
Marketers get made fun
of and B2B environment.
Cause they don't prove their value.
Yet, I stand here today
and I will be one of the
greatest businessmen of all time
and I know it to be true.
And it's because of the
way my mother parented me.
But I can't show you the chart,
or the Search Query,
or the data point that proves that.
I just know it to be true.
We have people in B2B sales
who make fun of marketers,
who say, prove to me that
worked that believe in God,
just say it one more time.
We have people, is what...
This was one of my favorite
moments in my career.
This is why I'm bringing it up.
I was in a, might've been
a keynote or conference
but it was a nice little dinner of eight,
10 very smart people and
a very big B2B company.
And the one guy was the head of sales,
and the one girl was head of marketing.
And he was going at her
and I was kind of like
not going at her very
mean or inappropriately.
But like, he was razzing
like, we do the real shit.
You get to have fun, waste money, right?
And I'm listening and I'm eating
and you know and then he started getting
a little bit into bully territory
and I kind of looked at him
and the gentleman was wearing a big cross.
And I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna put a flag in
the ground in this debate.
I go, sure.
I go, John.
I go, you believe in God.
He goes (indistinct)
The most.
More than any person here.
I believe in God the most.
I go cool.
So Catherine, you're saying
does all these things
but it's waste,
cause she can't prove
that it works, right?
Yeah.
I go, just do me a huge favor.
Right now, prove to me God exists.
It was one of the most
interesting conversations
in my career.
I am fascinated how
people don't understand
that branding and marketing
is the most important.
Does it have the difficulties to be judged
that sales doesn't of course it does.
That's why I love sales.
Sales is black and white.
I, Gary sold 19 things.
Yeah.
I Gary, the marketer, I've
been doing things for 15 years
that nobody could understand,
yet I sit here today with the luxury
of the beautiful accolades
that you gave me coming here
this wonderful audience
that's leaving comments left and right.
The nine figures of financial success
that I've created at a young age.
And I haven't even started
all because of marketing and branding.
So, it's a very powerful conversation.
- Thank you so much.
And I think I wanna give a shout out
to the sales and marketing team together,
because I think that's why
we have these meetings
is to bring us together
so we can work collaboratively as a team.
And I think everything that Gary's saying
is something we can definitely take away
from this conversation.
I think one of the other
things that we wanna talk about
so you brought up cold
calling a little bit
just a few moments ago
and we do have individuals
on our team that
that's part of their
job is the cold calling.
So how, what advice can you give to them
and how do you go about cold calling
in this environment and
do it in a creative way
where you can really
get someone's attention?
Because it is a little more difficult
than if you have all those,
you know, marketing leads
or you have a relationship
with somebody already.
- Look, you have to know the
mission you're on, right?
There's some people
that are part of an army
that go into enemy lines
without guns, during Vietnam.
And we're part of that
squad that, you know
that was a very different mission
than being a general
back at the Fort, right?
Or being somebody with the guns
back at precinct.
So to me, cold calling is
an incredible challenge.
Let there be no confusion.
I think nobody here is confused.
Very few people are fired up
in 2021 to get a cold call.
At the same token, it
is something that works.
There are people who have
charisma, charm, strategy.
I think the number one answer
to cold calling is compassion.
If you establish the person
that just picked up the phone
within the first 30 seconds,
three seconds, nine seconds,
that you are understanding
that is likely that they
are not excited to hear you.
However, you genuinely, your soul believe
you have something to bring to the table.
I think that is the
feeling you need to pass on
within those first six seconds.
And I would tell the people
that are on the front lines
to cold calling, don't apologize
under you know, don't be depressed.
I see so many people
reach out to me like Gary
I have to cold call and like, that's okay.
It's awesome.
And other people are like
cold calling is the best
cause they're awesome at it.
It's a, very narrow thing.
They've got that thick skin
and they're just a machine, you know?
And so, you know, I think,
Hey, don't be apologetic and
find compassion and then be,
if you're crushing it and you love it
add some things to your
repertoire and cleaning.
It's wonderful that you're just a machine
and an emotional and
you eventually get six.
Well, if you deployed compassionate,
empathy in the first six seconds
you might get 39 out of
those thousand calls.
- The point that you
bring up about compassion
kind of understanding the
person that you're talking to,
really knowing where they're
coming from, what they need.
That's a big theme for us this week,
this year, you know, know your MSP
the managed service providers
that we, that we serve.
And I know it's something
you talk a lot about
in your content
is understanding your audience
and really knowing them.
I'd love to hear a
little bit more from you
about the importance of that.
And we, always say we
put our partners first
but how can we go about doing
that in a bigger way in 2021?
And how do you go about doing that
at VaynerX and VaynerMedia?
- We ask them what they value the most.
Some value us, paying them more.
Some value us having me
give them a shout out
because they need brand.
Some value coming in and
learning how to do marketing
in exchange PARP barter
to them being a partner.
You know, bringing value
comes down to listening.
When you decide the value
you're gonna give someone
you're not providing value.
You're giving what you want to give.
That's a very different relationship
than asking someone what they want
and then being able to
figure out how to provide it.
And by the way, if you have kind candor
when somebody says
something you can't provide,
you can also articulate
that there are people ask me
for things all the time,
that in my early twenties
I would Dodge cause I
didn't want to be mean.
And that led me to be not
the man I wanted to be.
It wasn't bad but it
wasn't stand up enough.
And now in my older age, I'm like, look,
I can't do that, Karen.
That's not in the best interest
of what I wanna be doing.
And so, I think kind candor
on the back of listening
as a communication to your partners,
will lead to dramatically
more fruitful events.
- And I think part of
knowing our partners for
so we're talking about
sales and marketing a lot
but we have a ton of support people here.
We have implementation people here.
So I'd love to talk about support
and really understanding
our partners in that way,
understanding your audience,
and how we can add more value,
once there they become a customer.
I know you have a great
story about the liquor store
and someone who got a Jersey in the mail.
- [Gavy] Ooh, cause you see__
- I don't wanna give it away,
- [Gavy] Yeah, this is huge.
- but I'm
I would love for you to tell that story
or any other similar stories.
- Lemmie tell this one.
- Just a story.
This one's really good
because I think creativity
is the way to really win the B2B game.
And this was a very creative B2C example
that I do in B2B and all the time now.
If all of you had 49
targets to do business with,
your ability to follow them
on LinkedIn and Twitter
most likely Instagram as well
potentially. is very high.
You had follow.
If you then read what
they're interested in
and what they love in life,
you now have an opportunity
to create a tech connection point.
Sending somebody a bottle
of Dom Perignon and saying,
we'd love for you to consider us,
may not land if they are
rehabbing from alcoholism.
May not land if they just
don't like Champagne.
May not land with me who
really knows about wine
and doesn't want that Champagne
wants something smarter and cooler.
You didn't know anything about me.
I know that you just send
bottles of champagne to everybody
that's a big wig, not gonna land.
Intent didn't land because I know that
I don't mean anything to you.
You're trying to get
me through this thing.
However, let me paint
you a different story.
So, I'm writing this book called
The Thank you Economy back in 2011.
And it talks about providing value.
And I remember thinking, you know
I'd like a little bit more
tangible, you know, example.
It didn't work out for me.
It didn't make the book,
but it's here I am,
a decade later about to tell this story.
I called wine library and I said,
Hey, the next time you
get a first time customer
placed an order, I want
you to take the name.
I want you to go to Twitter search.
And I wanna see if you can
actually find the person.
So it took a while because
most people just weren't
on Twitter at that time.
And more importantly,
most people didn't have
unique enough names
or put where they were from.
It just took a while before
we finally found a person
with a unique enough
name who lived in Chicago
and on their Twitter account
and said they lived in Chicago.
It was a unique enough name.
We kind of thought we
had our person, right?
And so we monitored what
he was talking about.
So here's the chairman who
buys a case of Pinot Grigio.
I remember it like yesterday,
and all he talks about is Jay Cutler.
Jay Cutler was the former
quarterback of the Chicago bears.
And he is just on it.
Jay Cutler this, he's
the best that are there.
I love you to that (indistinct)
So, team calls me and says,
Hey, good news we got one.
We got this guy in Chicago.
He's a huge shade color fan.
I go, great.
I go, why you go to eBay and
buy a Jay Cutler signed Jersey.
I'm on the phone, I'm
about to get on a plane.
I remember it like yesterday.
And he...
They say Gary, that's like 400 bucks.
And what he bought was $180 case
that we were making $9 on, after shipping.
And I'm like, huh?
Less some time I got
the teacher to go do it.
So, we buy it.
We send it.
We say, thank you from one wine library.
Thank you for joining our family.
Hope you enjoy the Pinot Grigio.
So now I'm pumped, right?
I'm like, wait till this guy gets it.
He's gonna post it on Twitter.
He's gonna call up dah, dah, dah...
Two months later, nothing.
I like check if we have the right address,
rests about a month
later when I remembered.
And I'm so sad because I thought
this was gonna be so Epic.
We did some other little ones
got some little stuff here and there.
And then you get a phone call.
You know, it's funny.
I travel a lot.
Ironically again, getting on a plane
this time I was actually on the plane
like walking in, sat down in my seat
and the team says to me,
hey, we have some great news.
Do you remember the Jay Cutler thing?
I'll go, yeah, he what'd he do?
He goes, not him.
Get this.
So they go on to say,
Gary, somebody just
placed the $6,000 order
for Burgundy Wines, very high end stuff.
I'm like, cool.
What's that?
What, and let us read you the note
that he put in the notes here.
That's usually for gift notes,
but he wrote something else
which was, your Wine Library.
First of all, please hold these wines
cause they're expensive.
And it's a little hot here in Florida.
Why you do, you know,
wait this Florida, Texas
I don't recall at the time, but like,
we have warm weather that
can you hold the wines.
Two, you have an incredible
burgundy selection.
I'm also looking for Romanee
Conti and this and that,
can you please reach out to me?
Three, a couple of months
ago, a friend of mine,
let's just call him Dan.
Dan received a Jay Cutler
signed Jersey in the mail
after he bought some wine from you.
A, that's incredible.
B, I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan.
Have a good day.
To me, that was just unbelievable.
To me that was everything I believe in
which is doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
We, clearly showed a human being.
We went out of our way to get to know them
and do something special,
surprised, and delighted
that created word of mouth,
not on the internet like we anticipated,
but in his circle
led to somebody becoming
aware of our business,
and led to this moment.
That's called business.
And I think everybody
who's watching right now,
has 50 to 100 people they're
targeting to do business with.
I couldn't recommend more for
them to follow their interests
and engage with people
around their interests.
Whether it's sending them
a, you know, a violin
with a note attached to it,
whether it's just replying to them
around the things they like
because, they also love
Dave Matthews band.
And that they'll nerd out on that.
And that will lead.
This is about humanity.
This is about what you would do
if you were in the same Country Club,
or part of the same Elks Club
or part of the same Book Club
with somebody that potentially
you could do business with
you would be human,
and you would win around
human interactions.
I just believe that
this scales your ability
to do it with 200 people instead of two.
- Yeah, and I think that's something
every single one of us can take away.
Whether we're in marketing,
sales, support, success
we're all interfacing with
partners in different ways,
and that's something we can take away.
And there's a great example of that.
The first time I ever
went to an MSP trade show,
I was at a table with a
bunch of CEOs that we serve
and many service providers.
We talked about business for 10 minutes.
We talked about Star Wars for
an hour and a half (laughs)
and it was just that human connection.
And I think there's so many opportunities
for each one of us, regardless
of our role to really act on,
on what you're saying Gary
and make those human connections.
I know we only have a few minutes left.
- Let me just say one more thing .
- So, Ooh yeah no, go for it.
- Let's not demonize technology,
which a lot of people are doing
because they wanna use it
as an excuse to not do it.
Realize that technology is the gateway
to real interaction and
your life will change.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
And we just have a couple of minutes.
So I'm gonna pick one question here.
We have a lot of good ones,
but we're growing as a company.
It's very exciting to
see where we're going.
And I think how do we...
one of the big questions that we had
from multiple people actually was
how do we keep teams motivated,
and keep the culture?
The culture is the company
culture at the same time
as we scale and become much bigger?
- The answer is listening
and I'll give you the practical execution.
- Mmh.
- Do obnoxious amounts
of coffees, happy hours,
random pop-up or after hours
Zooms with your people?
Talk.
Engage.
Like it's when, it's like children.
If children feel like
their parents are in it,
they end up being better people.
It's not super complicated.
Make your people know that
you're in it with them.
Have meetings, be with them,
do random fun stuff,
have a quiz show for
the employees at 7:00 PM
once every month.
You know, just do a random email at night
when you're feeling the
culture's a little down
and say, everybody on this
Zoom Link at 10:00 AM tomorrow
and just shoot the share.
Yeah like, be human.
I mean it.
- Any final words of
wisdom before we wrap up
and thank you again so much for your time
and all of this wonderful insight
- Content is the unlock.
It just is.
You may not see it.
You may not think you're good at it.
You may not want to do it,
but it's been so consistent
and obvious that it will continue.
Let me show you something real quick.
You think Zoom and Tik Tok,
and Instagram are crazy?
This is coming.
Now, eventually when it's humongous,
as big as I'm going to predict right now,
I don't think it's going
to be some huge device
that's gonna be like this.
I think it's gonna be closer to contact,
lenses are much smaller.
But in the next 15 to 30 years,
we will live in a VR world.
And you're gonna think the iPhone
and Tik ToK was child's play.
You will be in virtual conferences.
You will be doing virtual meetings.
You will, you will.
And, if you're 60 right
now and you're watching
be like, good, I'm not gonna
have to deal with that.
I'm gonna retire.
That's fine.
I understand.
But the thesis remains.
Figure out how to be human.
Figure out how to bring value.
Figure out how to do content.
And this, I think of this
as, this is a marathon.
This is coming.
So, how do you train for a marathon?
Well, you run on the treadmill every day.
To me, LinkedIn and Instagram and Twitter
and making content
starting your own PodCast.
This is training for the race,
is training for the race.
I really, really need you
to train for the race.
It's how all of society
is going to be structured.
Definitely business.
- That's amazing.
Thank you so much again to
everybody who's listening.
Definitely go check out GaryVee.
This keynote was fantastic.
There's so much that
each one of us can take
moving into 2021 to make
this the best year at data
and the best year as a
team that we'll ever have.
And Gary, thank you.
Thank you for your time
and the great answers and
just you're wonderful.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Thank you Datto.
Thank you so much, I
see some of your tweets.
I'm gonna try to get into during the day,
GaryVee if you have a follow up question.
I love all of you, healthy 2021.
(upbeat music)
You do virtuals, what's up?
It's GaryVee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you,
please subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.